So how's Democrats yesterday, as we discussed,
they were about to do release the resolution
to formalize the impeachment inquiry into
Donald Trump.
So understand that so far they've been pre-interviewing
witnesses in private, in accordance with the
law.
By the way, as I will shortly remind you in
the next segment, a very interesting segment
upcoming.
This is now an impeachment inquiry resolution.
The house is expected to vote on it Thursday
and it outlines the process that is going
to be taking place to inquire about whether
Donald Trump should be impeached by the house
of representatives ultimately subsequently
to be voted on by the Senate.
What does the resolution say?
Well, for starters, at its conclusion, the
inquiry is going to create a public rec report
of their findings.
And, uh, this is important, uh, in the sense
that it is one of the areas that has been
heavily criticized by Republicans, that everything
is happening quote in secret.
Well, in reality, nothing has actually happened
yet.
There's just been pre-interviewing of witnesses.
But at the conclusion of this inquiry, there
will be a public report that is going to be
issued.
Now importantly to Donald Trump, who as you
may know, has been complaining about, there's
no due process.
I'm not getting any due process here, even
though we simply didn't get to that point
yet.
Nothing wrong has happened so far.
The resolution outlines the due process that
Donald Trump is going to, to, to get, and
you can make the argument that it's actually
generous to Donald Trump.
The resolution outlines some new due process
rights for the president of the United States.
Overall in a sort of balanced, sober rational
analysis, there's really nothing controversial
in the resolution whatsoever.
It's very similar to the process that was
employed, uh, during bill Clinton's impeachment
back in 1998.
The difference being that with bill Clinton,
there was this independent council report.
Remember this guy Ken Starr, who was brought
in to investigate bill Clinton.
Uh, there was a report which came, which presented
was presented to the house committees involved
by the independent council, uh, specifically
through the judiciary committee.
This time it's a little bit different.
The house itself will be doing the investigating
and it will be uh, the entity, the judiciary
committee will be the entity issuing the full
report rather than receiving it from an, uh,
a special prosecutor, independent prosecutor.
So now the rubber is sort of going to start
meeting the road.
And what I mean by that is we're going to
see very quickly if Republicans and Donald
Trump settle down over, there are no guidelines
and no due process because the resolution
gives them everything that they've been asking
for.
Now of course there is a chance, call me a
skeptic, call me a cynic.
There's a chance that it wasn't really about
process and guidelines all along.
It was just something that Republicans and
Trump grasped onto like a last desperate straw
to try to stop what it is that is going on.
But in any case, if we go by what they've
said, Republicans have been asking for their
own subpoena power to bring in witnesses.
They are being given that by this resolution.
Donald Trump has been asking or demanding
or complaining about not having due process.
He is getting that.
We have very clear guidelines here for what
this process is going to look like and what
the deliverable is going to be.
Deliverable by the way, doesn't have to be
a bad word, although when Donald Trump uses
it, it often alludes to corruption.
The deliverable in this case will be a report,
a public report.
I'm summarizing the impeachment inquiry.
Uh, Trump want to do process and the route
resolution gives him that.
And it's really important to remember that
the resolution also by the way outlines, and
this is where it starts to get very interesting.
Uh, the resolution outlines the possibility
of public hearings, which would be just endlessly
fascinating.
Uh, Congressman Jim McGovern, who's a Democrat
from Massachusetts, chairman of the rules
committee, he released the resolution yesterday
afternoon.
I actually bumped into Jim McGovern over the
weekend in North Hampton, Massachusetts at
the world famous Haymarket cafe.
Very exciting moment for me.
He clearly forgot who I was and had no recollection
of having met me.
But regardless, Jim McGovern releasing for
us yesterday the resolution.
So prepare yourselves now for just the new
wave of bad faith arguments from Republicans
about how this is still unfair, how it's still
a witch hunt, how it is still a terrible unfair
example of presidential harassment and also
expect the white house to again start moving
the bar to come up with new excuses for why
they are going to be ignoring and directing
everyone under their purview to ignore all
subpoenas because before it was, there's no
guidelines, there's no due process.
It's an open ended secret thing that's going
on.
Now we've been told here are the guidelines,
here is the due process and there will be
a public report after possibly public hearings,
they will come up with something new to justify
it in their minds and in the minds of their
supporters.
Um, why they are going to not cooperate with
this inquiry.
What I am most looking forward to is that
in the resolution, this is just great.
It mentions 45 minutes of uninterrupted questioning
of witnesses by each side.
Democrats would get 45 minutes and then Republicans
would get 45 minutes with witnesses in public
testimony.
If you've watched congressional testimony
before, you probably remember that before
there is even a prelude and one question asked.
They're low on time because oftentimes each
member of the house will get five minutes.
It's just not enough time still.
Sometimes there are fireworks, but it is not
enough time.
45 minutes of uninterrupted questioning of
a single witness, the fireworks and the implosions
that we could see in 45 minutes of straight
questioning could be absolutely glorious.
And I am very, very much looking forward to
it.
And this may be, it may be in the end, Republicans
shooting themselves in the foot by demanding
transparency because now they have it and
it doesn't look like it's the type of transparency
that is going to be particularly good for
the narrative that they have been crafting
more upcoming on this.
I am sure I want to hear from you.
How do you think the vote will go in the house?
Well, the, the most, uh, straight forward
prediction is just a party line, a straight
party line vote.
Um, and what do you expect w if and when these
public impeachment inquiry hearings actually
get going?